[Applaudissements]
il a le sens de la mise en scène
elon musk de la fumée du feu et des
lasers pour présenter le nouveau venu de
chez tesla et le voici un design
inattendu mais il s'est passé d'autres
choses inattendues
pendant cette présentation la
camionnette électrique qui veut
concurrencer le f 150 est construite
avec le même métal que les lanceurs de
ce pays sexe et le cyber trucks et son
nom est censé être incassable jusqu'ici
tout va bien mais quand le directeur de
la conception chez tesla s'attaque aux
vitres ça n'était pas prévu c'était
peut-être un peu fort dillon musk alors
on peut retenter sur l'autre vitre il
reste de la place à l'amélioration
mais elon musk a de quoi se rassurer un
peu
tesla vient de renouer avec la
rentabilité et surtout ses usines
produisent maintenant à une cadence
profitable trois cent cinquante mille
véhicules par an à l'usiné de fremont en
californie par exemple
c'est trois fois plus que l'année
dernière une nouvelle giga à usine a été
construite en dix mois dans la banlieue
de shanghai est une autre va voir le
jour en allemagne car tesla a désormais
beaucoup de concurrence dans le secteur
de la voiture électrique que ce soit
volvo qu'il veut que la moitié de ses
ventes soit des véhicules électriques
d'ici 2025 ou ford qui convertit même la
légendaire mustang en v ux électrique
est cité cela al'avantage d'être
pionnière dans le domaine la marque
c'est aussi faire parler d'elle
mais c'est mathieu prost radio canada
montréal